in this paper we address an important
open problem in material modeling what
happens when light scatters multiple
times on rough material surfaces in
image synthesis accurately describing
light matter interactions is important
for materials to obtain a realistic look
however the multiple light matter
interactions that we can see in this
figure are absent from many surface
appearance models here's an example of
this problem
rendering white glass should be simple
but we can see that the rougher the
glass is the darker its appearance
becomes even though it should be simple
modeling the appearance of glass that is
at the same time rough and white is
almost impossible with the current
material models many material models
such as those rough dielectric plates
are called micro facet materials because
the underlying mathematical model
assumes that their interfaces are made
of microscopic imperfections that we
call facets those facets are too small
to be visible but the way they are
statistically oriented changed away
light interacts with the material
causing its rough appearance many
rendering systems model only the
contribution of the first bounce of
light the contribution of multiple
bounces is unknown and it is simply set
to zero as if it were neglected
however on very rough micro surfaces the
amount of light that scatters multiple
times is significant and should not be
neglected to avoid energy loss and the
noticeable darkening of the material
appearance in summary modeling rough
materials correctly with multiple
scattering is a challenging problem our
multiple scattering model presented in
this paper opens up the possibility of
modeling rough materials correctly in a
practical manner beyond fixing the
darkening problem our goal is to derive
a physically based model that is able to
make accurate predictions compared to
reference data
more specifically we derived the
multiple scattering component of a
specific kind of micro surface the Smith
micro surface model because it is based
on simple assumptions and makes accurate
predictions for single scattering it has
received widespread industrial adoption
and is considered the academic state of
the art in computer graphics for
modeling many materials but can we
extend this model for multiple
scattering and could it be practically
incorporated into
like psdf plugin these are the questions
we are interested in our main insight is
to transform this surface scattering
problem into a volume scattering problem
which is easier to solve to achieve that
we show that the Smith micro surface
model can be derived as a special case
of the micro flag theory for volumes
really formulate the Smith micro surface
as a volume with additional constraints
to enforce the presence of a sharp
interface this volumetric analogy is
very convenient because we know how to
compute the light scattering in volumes
it depends on two functions that we
derive for this new kind of volume the
first one is the free path distribution
which tells us how long a ray can travel
in a medium before finding an
intersection on the micro surface the
equivalent question is what is the
height of the next intersection once an
intersection is found we need to know in
which direction the light is scattering
again this is given by a volumetric
phase function which depends on both the
base material of the surface and the
distribution of the micro facets we
derived the phase function for three
different surface materials diffuse
conductive and dielectric and common
micro facet distributions such as
Beckman and GG X now that we know the
free path and the phase function of this
volumetric model we know exactly how the
light scatters in the medium from the
light propagated in this medium emerges
a distribution that has all the expected
properties of a classic surface psdf it
is energy conserving and reciprocal
furthermore it is exactly the classic
single scattering VSD F based on the
Smith micro surface model but with the
addition of higher order scattering now
that we know that the model is
mathematically correct we are interested
in its predictive power how accurate is
this new model to answer this question
we need some reference data to compare
the predictions of the model to a common
way to validate models is to compare
their predictions to simulated data
obtained by ray tracing triangulated
surfaces contrary to real-world
acquisition the surface used in the
simulation has known material and
statistics and the collected data are
free of noise there is thus no degrees
of freedom left to mesh the parameters
of the model to the simulation this is
why this validation procedure is widely
used in the field of optical physics and
therefore we chose this to validate our
model we generated random surfaces with
known Beckman statistics and did a ray
tracing simulation on them by comparing
the predictions of our multiple
scattering model to the results of the
ray tracing simulation we found our psdf
model to accurately predict both the
albedo and angular distribution of the
accident energy among the scattering
orders and this for a large variety of
materials roughnesses anisotropy and
inclinations in our supplemental
material we provide an exhaustive set of
such validation results to make the
model practical we implement two
procedures evaluation and important
sampling since the PSD f is the
expectation of all the paths that can be
traced on the micro surface importance
sampling can be done straightforwardly
by generating one path we construct an
unbiased stochastic estimate by tracing
one path and evaluating the phase
functions at each intersection with next
event estimation as in classical part
racing with important sampling and this
stochastic evaluation we have everything
required to implement a classic psdf
plugin furthermore our implementation is
analytic and does not use per B SDF pre
computed data which makes our BS DX
usable with textured abidos roughness
and ni so true P in the supplemental
materials we provide a document
describing the tutorial implementation
for various materials and ready to use
plugins for the Mitsuba physically-based
render now let's have a look at some
results this image shows a collection of
bottles with micro facet materials the
energy loss is significant if multiple
scattering is neglected especially on
dielectrics without multiple scattering
rough transmittance appears unnatural
which is hard to compensate for by
tuning parameters with our multiple
scattering model we simulate the
expected appearance of rough glass and
metals without tuning any parameters our
model is robust and behaves as expected
even with high roughness values we can
see that the model avoids the darkening
effects and even produces interesting
emerging effects like color saturation
this can be observed on this rough
diffuse material since the absorption
spectrum of the material is repeatedly
multiplied after each bounce on the
micro surface there if
color appears more saturated after
multiple bounces this emerging effect
can also be seen on this gold conductor
material the unsaturated single
scattering gold conductor appeared
strangely dull thanks to our model the
introduction of multiple scattering
restores the shiny appearance expected
from gold note that since our model is
parametric and does not depend on any
pre computed data we fully support
textured input which is important for
creating visually rich images as an
example this is a dielectric with
textured roughness and an isotropy
thanks for watching